hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today we're doing the Q&A video
associated with I think it was the 8th
idea of entanglement quantum
entanglement the seventh idea we did was
quantum mechanics and we gave you
basically some of the textbook stuff
about wave functions and how they
collapse when you measure them in video
number eight we went a little bit deeper
into the idea of entanglement which is
something that truly separates quantum
mechanics from classical mechanics and
it let us talk about some of the more
modern formulations of quantum mechanics
formulations that are purportedly a
little bit more rigorous and
well-defined than the Copenhagen
interpretation that you read about in
textbooks opinions differ about whether
or not that is true but I'll in this
video answer a couple questions about
entanglement generally and then go in a
little bit to more detail about how
things work in the many-worlds
interpretation which is my favorite one
I didn't do this in the original video
because I've done things like this on
videos online elsewhere but there's a
completist aspect that indicates that we
should probably do it here so it I think
it thought about the different questions
that were asked and I think that it will
be useful before diving into the answers
to talk a little bit more about this
example of quantum mechanical spins
because spins really when you talk about
entanglement and the wave function of
different parts of the system
interacting with each other in different
ways
spins provide a very very nice explicit
example that you can control much better
that you sort of know what all the
different options are in a way that we
talk about the position of something or
the momentum of something that's harder
to do for the basic reason that there
are an infinite number of possible
positions you could measure but there
are only two outcomes you can get when
you measure the spin let's say an
electron there's there are higher spin
particles before an electron there are
only two possible outcomes you could get
which is why spins are characterized by
qubits quantum mechanical versions of
bits a bit is either 0 or 1 classically
quantum mechanically it's some
superposition of 0 or 1 and spins are
represented quantum mechanically by
qubits the spin is a physical thing a
qubit is an abstract notion but they
line up in this particular
way of thinking about things so let's
talk a little bit about how you find out
about spins in the first place and what
this teaches us about spins because
again I don't like to keep anything in
suspense we're going to use spins to
think about the uncertainty principle in
quantum mechanics in a slightly
different way what super positions mean
what basis states are which I mentioned
in the previous Q&A video and then we
can use that technology to talk about
entanglement in a more detailed way so
we measure the spin of a particle by
something called well one way to do it
something called the stern-gerlach
experiment and I'm not gonna go into
great detail about this I'm gonna give
sort of a theorists version of the
stern-gerlach experiment this is an
experiment that was actually done by
monsieurs Stern and Gerlach but we're
not gonna go into the experimental
details the basic idea is that if you
have a magnetic field and it is an
inhomogeneous magnetic field so it's
sort of more pointy at one end than the
other so it's like
a line a set of lines of magnetic field
that sort or originally spaced out and
they come together okay and you pass an
electron through it the spin of the
electron the electron is little spinning
particle that has an electric charge so
it's a little magnet and will be
deflected either in the direction of the
magnetic field or opposite to the
direction of the magnetic field if it
were spinning such that its axis or
pointing along or against the magnetic
field so I'm not gonna try to draw an
accurate depiction of the magnetic field
because that's hard so here's my
magnetic field B Z so we're thinking
that in a little coordinate system here
you'll see Y X Y Z our electron our spin
let's how do I draw the electron not to
say II - the electron is going in along
moving along the y axis and it
encounters this magnetic field and the
point is that you might think I'm not
sure if you should think this or not but
you might think that if the electron is
a little spinning magnet it has a
magnetic pole and it could be pointed
anywhere right that pole is aligned in
some direction and therefore when it
goes through it could be deflected up or
down or any intermediate value right but
quantum mechanics comes along and says
in fact the electron only
goes slightly up or slightly down and
this is what we would call
spin-up or spin-down okay there are two
possibilities that's why it's a cubit
it's the so it's a quantum mechanical
version of 0 or 1 0 is spin up one is
spin down now there's actually
subtleties here whether or not you need
quantum mechanics to explain this to
valued Mis rather than infinite number
of continuum of values but we're just
going to take it as a fact that this is
we're not comparing classical mechanics
to quantum mechanics we're just saying
this is the quantum mechanical answer so
you represent then the state of the
particle sy by some combination alpha
times spin up plus beta times spin down
this is the wave function of the spin
this is a slight modification to look
less scary of the Dirac notation that
Paul Dirac invented he would have
written alpha up and then so there's a
line and a right angle bracket plus beta
down angle bracket and this is called a
ket this particular notation because
this is half of a bracket so there are
both bras and ket's a bra looks like
this oops that's a bra for physicists
this is a ket we're not going to use any
of that notation okay but I'm just going
to use this simplified parenthesis
notation it's more than good enough for
what we want to do okay and you know
that these numbers alpha and beta these
are two complex numbers these are the
amplitudes for observing the particle to
be spin up or spin down so the
probability of in this experiment
measuring spin up is magnitude of alpha
squared probability of measuring spin
down in this experiment is the magnitude
of beta squared and therefore you know
that alpha squared plus beta squared
equals 1 because the sum of the
probabilities has to be equal 1 and you
only have two choices good so I think
all that you know I sort of glossed over
that but I mentioned things like this
before but now let's do something a
little bit more complicate
we measured there the spin in the Z
direction so we talked about spin up we
always imagined the Z direction is
pointing towards the sky so we talked
about spin up versus spin down by
measuring the spin in the Z direction
but we could also measure it in other
directions we could measure it in the X
direction it's hard to measure it in the
y direction because the electron is
moving in the Y direction but X is easy
enough so let's do the following
experiment
let's send the electron in okay let's
measure it in the Z direction so it do
what we just did and I'm not gonna I'm
gonna run out of room if I keep drawing
all the different options here so let's
just imagine that what we got was spin
up okay I could do better than that we
got a spin up outcome good but now and
again remember X Y Z now let's measure
again the spin but this time with
respect to I suppose I should draw it
the other way around to be completely
fair the X magnetic field oriented in
the X direction okay so then again it's
going to split and in fact you you could
get just be consistent and draw it as a
solid line you could get either yeah you
could get either spin right if you want
or spin left so let's call this spin let
me see right all depends it's yeah it's
not the notation is not gonna look very
good but like all that's been writing
spin left okay you get the point it
turns out that if you do this if you
measure the spin in the Z direction and
you get spin up then every time that you
put it in the X Direction spin
measurement device you will get either
spin left or spin right that's been
oriented along the x axis and you cannot
predict which one you are going to get
okay just keep that fact in mind again
and then let's say that you measure spin
left okay let's say that's what you
measure and then you decide to do it
again the same electron and measure it
in the zero
okay so he had the electron he measured
in the Z direction we found it was spin
up we measured it in the X direction we
found it was spin left now we're gonna
measure in the Z direction again you
could potentially think I don't know if
you would think this or not but not
trying to put ideas into your head but
you could potentially think that there
were two separate things one called the
spin along the X direction and another
called the spin along the z direction in
that case you would think okay I've
measured the spin along the z direction
it's up I've measured the spin along the
X direction it's left therefore if I
measure the Z spin again
it will be up again because if I didn't
do this X Direction thing if I just did
this we just had an electron come in
measure it along Z and I find that it is
spin up then if I measure it along Z
again I will always get spin up again
this is a reflection of the fact that
this measurement in some sense measures
this this going through well let's be
SuperDuper clear about this because
we're trying to be accurate here going
through the electric field the going
through the magnetic field does not
measure the spin of the electron it
evolves the wave function of the
electron into two components that are
separated in space what we imagine is
that we then measure it okay so it's not
the splitting that measures it cuz
that's not entangle it with anything but
when we actually measure it we need to
entangle it with the environment so we
have some screen or some electric field
monitor that has an arrow that says oh
one left went up down whatever it did
okay so we're imagining that we both put
it through the magnetic field and
measured the spin of the electron so
just according to our usual our
old-fashioned Copenhagen way of thinking
when we measured it and we saw that it
was spin up the wavefunction collapsed
and it's now spin up that's what it is
so when it goes through B Z again is
always gonna measure spin up it's not
gonna be a superposition of both where
as well we find here that so that might
be what you think that we measured spin
up and that's done with it
well we actually find here if we go
through the Z spin a Z magnetic field
again is an equal superposition of spin
up and spin down
okay so putting the electron through the
x-direction magnetic field and measuring
it to be one thing or the other thing
turned it back into a superposition of
spin-up and spin-down
in the z direction so what that means is
and maybe this is not a surprise at all
again I'm not telling you should be
surprised what it means is there are not
two separate things that spin along the
X direction and the spin along the z
direction there's only one thing to spin
of the particle and when you measure it
you collapse it into some state that is
either spin up or spin down with respect
to the direction in which you're
measuring it and the way that we
expressed that is the state that is spin
up that we've written like this we can
write as 1 over the square root of 2
spin right plus 1 over the square root
of 2 spin down spin left so what this
notation means is that this is a wave
function this is sy you might want to
call it sy for a spin up spin electron
and you can rewrite it as in in terms of
the left and right bases and if you had
gotten spin down it would be 1 over
square root of 2 these are conventions
that we work out and I'm skipping steps
spin right minus 1 over square root of 2
is been left so in either one of these
two cases if it was spin up or spin down
when we measure it along the x direction
there's a 50-50 chance that we're going
to get spin left or spin right in the X
direction because these are two the
coefficients are 1 over square root of 2
with a plus or minus out front squared
in either case you get 1/2 so there's a
half of the chance of getting it left or
right so there's yet another way of
thinking about this if you look at if
you stare at these equations remember
Hilbert space the space of all wave
functions is a vector space ok you can
add them scale them by numbers etc so
what this is telling us is we can write
the vector space for Hilbert space of
the qubit of the single spin in terms of
basis directions spin up and spin down
and we can express any wave function sy
let me give it a color any wave function
sy is just a vector
in this vector space so it has if you
did this this would be if you wrote psy
as alpha spin-up plus beta spin down
this component would be alpha this
component would be beta okay there you
go
and these equations telling you that
spin up is a superposition a combination
a sum of spin right and spin left and
likewise for spin down can be thought of
as saying I hope I'm gonna get the signs
right here you know I'm again making
this up as I go along but basically it's
saying that spin left and spin right are
two different axes in this same vector
space two axes that are rotated with
respect to what the old axes were so the
axis that we label spin right might be
like that and the access we label spin
left might be like that you can actually
work out what they are there's a 50-50
chance that I got the labels right in
the directions right maybe there's only
25% chance but you get the point
the point is that because you're in a
two dimensional vector space what you're
doing when you're measuring spin up
versus spin down or spin left versus
spin right is you're making two
different choices about how to talk
about the vector that you have likewise
this this vector sigh I can still write
it in terms of components here this is a
different two sets of components in the
different axes spin left and spin right
all of which is to say the difference
between vertical spin and horizontal
spin is not two separate quantities it's
two different ways of talking about the
same underlying state that the that the
thing could be in and the reveal here
the reason why this is worth chatting
about is this is the origin of the
uncertainty principle okay remember we
talked about the uncertainty principle
and in the context of position and
momentum and we said if you were
completely localized in position you had
no idea what your momentum is and we
said if you're completely localized in
momentum you have no idea what your
position is the same thing is true for X
spin and Z spin if you know what your X
spin is so let's say you know what your
x been
let's say you are purely spinrite okay
let's draw you this way here is Sai
spinrite
okay well then it's clear that you are
maximally uncertain about whether you
are spin up or spin down in the Z
direction right and likewise if you are
pure spin left you would be maximally
uncertain as well and vice versa if you
are maximally certain about whether you
are spin up or spin down in the Z
direction you'd have no idea what your
spin was in the X direction so that's a
reflection of the uncertainty principle
it's saying that if you if you believe
that the you know wave that I suggested
you think about it there is no such
thing as the X bin or Z spin it as an
inherent property of the particle these
are outcomes of possible observations
you can make okay they are not
pre-existing things and I'm emphasizing
all this for a very good reason because
now let's start talking about
entanglement okay keep these keep these
equations in mind the fact that up and
down are related to left and right by
this simple transformation okay
so the questions come in because I think
the biggest question I really want to
absolutely get around is isn't
entanglement just kind of like classical
correlations in some sense so I'm gonna
talk about entanglement
versus correlation the example that was
given what if like you buy a packet of
two gloves okay and you know that
there's a left-handed glove and a
right-handed glove in there so you know
that if you open one and pick one out of
random if it's the left-handed glove you
instantly know the other one is
right-handed isn't entanglement just
like that so the answer is no the
entanglement is not just like that
entanglement is more than that and
almost exactly that example was given by
John Bell
he gave an example that he called
brittle men's socks I'm not again
completely clear that I'm spelling
Bertil man's name right so John Bell
wrote you know John Bell when he was
inventing the Bell inequalities he's
incredibly influenced by the
einstein-podolsky-rosen argument to EPR
argument
with these entangled spins you can
measure once he would happen somewhere
else and so what he was trying to say is
that entanglement is more than just
classical correlation sober tlemen socks
is the idea that this guy who was a
friend of bells another physicist at
CERN
I think Reinhold Reinhard Bertil Minh
would he had this cork of his personal
style where when he wore socks which was
every day but he would always wear two
socks of different colors okay they were
never the same color so Bell says if you
see Bertil Minh coming down the hallway
and you know he walks around a door and
one of his legs is sticking out first
and you see Oh on that leg he has a pink
sock then you instantly know that
whatever is going on on the other leg
it's not pink because he always wears
two different colored socks okay so
that's an example of a classical
correlation do you measure one thing and
you know something just like it you know
something from it about something from
that you know something about something
completely different okay but Bell's
point is that that's not what
entanglement is for a few reasons let me
just give you the most important reason
here we talked about
let's here's Alice and Bob with their
spins so here's Alice she has a spin
here's Bob planet Bob over here there's
another spin and the state of both of
them by the way these are called Bell
States this way of writing these spin
States there's a state that is one over
square root of two spin up for Alice
spin down for Bob just as an example no
actually let me it'll be easier for the
subsequent math if I do both spins the
same plus one over square root of two
it's been down for Alice spin down for
ball remember it doesn't matter whether
or not they're aligned or anti aligned
what matters is that they're related
what matters is if you measure one then
you instantly know the other one okay in
either case they would be entangled one
way or the other
and so someone said I think there was
one question that said you know isn't
entanglement just the same as
superposition or at least what is the
difference between them so superposition
is just possible with one particle with
one qubit right here is a superposition
this is a expressing the spin up state
as a superposition of spin right and
spin left and this is crucially
important you know by the way and we'll
skip ahead a little bit note that people
want to say sometimes you know how many
worlds are there in the many worlds
theory of quantum mechanics or they want
to say you know when the electron goes
through the double slits is there a
world in which he goes through the
right-hand slit in a world in which he
goes to the left-hand slit and that is
not my point of view at all I know some
people have points of view like that
David Deutsch has a point of view kind
of like that I don't want to try to say
exactly what this point of view is but
it's related to that it's sort of a
fine-grained version of what the worlds
are my statement is that the world's
only come into existence when you
experience decoherence and we'll talk
about that a little bit just writing it
as a superposition doesn't mean it's two
worlds at all and that should be
perfectly obvious because this equation
right here is saying that the same state
can be written either as spin up 100% or
an equal superposition of spin right and
spin left so is it one world or two
worlds right it depends on how you write
it but that's silly the number of worlds
shouldn't depend on how you write it and
my way of figuring that out is just say
this is just one world because this spin
is not entangled with anything at all
entanglement is a relationship between
two different parts of the quantum
system and when you only have one part
there's no such things entanglement but
there is superposition okay so here is
Ellis involved and if Alice measures her
state and she finds it spin up then Bob
will measure his and he finds it spin up
but so I tried to get this across when I
talk about the EPR experiment but I
think I didn't necessarily do a very
good job so let me try to do a little
bit better sure this is like Behrman
socks in the sense that if I measure the
spin along the X along the Z Direction I
know what Bob will get along
but I can use these equations okay for
the state of one spin to rewrite this
state of Alice involve in terms of spin
left and spin right in other words Alice
could choose to measure her spin along
the Z direction and then we know what
Bob will get along the Z direction but
Alice could also choose independently
rather than measuring along the Z
direction she could measure it along the
x direction and it turns out go through
the math again 50-50 chance I get the
plus minus signs right here but this is
equivalent to spin right for Alice spin
right for Bob plus one over square root
of two spin left for Alice
spend left for Bob which means again
modulo minus signs which means that had
Alice chosen to measure the spin along
the x axis instead of the z axis it
would still be true that she knows what
bob is going to get and the problem with
that the reason why that is profound and
and and weird is that
well what Einstein in Podolsky and Rosen
said is look I don't know what alice is
gonna measure I don't know what answer
she's gonna get but I can imagine that
she measures something and she's gonna
get something okay let's say she gets
spin up when she measures in the Z
Direction then if I refuse to
countenance the possibility of spooky
action at a distance I instantly know
what Bob's gonna get he's gonna get spin
up okay therefore EPR say it must have
always been the case that bob was going
to get spin up if he chose to measure
the Z spin of his particle because Alice
reveals that you know there must be some
pre-existing reality is what EP are
saying about Bob's sorry but the Z
component of Bob spin they needed it was
spin up if we were in the world where
when Alice measured she was going to get
spin up and then they also say look
Alice could have chosen to measure the X
spin she would have gotten some answer
let's say it's spin right okay she gets
an answer is all the point it doesn't
matter what the answer is let's say it's
been right then instantly we know what
Bob is gonna get
no signal can travel to Bob therefore it
must have always been the case the bob
was going to get spin right so EPR say
the whole point of their argument which
is often missed by people who talk about
the argument the whole point of their
argument is it must be the case if you
don't have spooky action at a distance
that it was simultaneously true that bob
was always gonna get spin up if he
measured in the Z direction and he was
always gonna get spin right if he
measured in the X direction but quantum
mechanics says that can never happen
that's the uncertainty principle you
cannot have a state of your particle in
which with a hundred percent certainty
you will always get spin up if you
measure along Z and spin right if you
measure along X ok so that's why they
say quantum mechanics must be incomplete
and you see that this relationship is
deeper than simple classical correlation
because the whole point of the socks is
that there is some fact of the matter
about what the socks are right you don't
know what color Bertil men's socks are
but he knows I mean it's known someone
could know if you did know you wouldn't
be changing the condition of the world
you wouldn't be collapsing the
wavefunction or anything like that
quantum mechanical entanglement is a
deeper and more profound phenomenon than
that there is no fact of the matter
about whether Alice's spin is up or down
before she measures it there's also no
fact of the matter about whether it's
been right or it's been left before she
measures it and when she makes a
measurement we instantly know something
new about what Bob is going to do he
doesn't know it so he didn't send him a
signal but we instantly know something
about it again this is not something
that has any analog in classical physics
okay that's why you need that's why
Bell's Theorem says that unless you do
something like super determinism or
many-worlds you need some non locality
in your theory of physics and there's no
non locality needed to understand Bertil
Minh socks so there is a difference
between quantum entanglement and
classical correlation that's important
okay another question was how do we
entangle particles
and this is a very important question
actually you should have talked more
about this because this gets into the
question of you know is there a
difference between entanglement the
process of entangling versus simply
interacting is it true that every time
two quantum systems interact with each
other they become entangled or not right
so no it is not true that every time two
quantum systems interact with each other
they become entangled the point is that
you entangle only when the two quantum
systems interact in such a way that if
you think about either one of those
quantum systems as a superposition of
different possibilities then the two
terms in the superposition interact
differently with what you are
interacting with okay so the classic
example not control the whole thing
again but Schrodinger's cat you know we
had the alive cat there's the alive cat
and then we had the sleeping cat let
sleeping cats lie here
and the point was that a photon in the
environment could come along in such a
way that if the cat were alive the
photon would hit the cat and be absorbed
whereas if the cat were asleep the
photon would just go on its way that is
why the cat becomes entangled with the
environment if the cat is purely alive
it's still a quantum mechanical system
but every single I say alive and alive
in a sleep awake if the cat is purely
awake
it's still a quantum mechanical system
but every photon that interacts with it
interacts with it in the same way so no
entanglement happens the photon is
either absorbed or not is only when the
cat is in a superposition that the
photon interacts differently with one
term in the superposition versus another
one that's when entanglement happens so
if you like think of an electron falling
in a gravitational field okay rather
than a magnetic field the electron can
be used superposition spin up and spin
down it's clearly interacting with the
gravitational field right because it's
falling it's being pulled down but both
the spin up part and the spin down part
fall exactly in the same way therefore
there is no entanglement between the
gravitational field and the electron
okay that's the difference between
entanglement and interaction interaction
can interact with the whole thing all
the terms in the superposition in the
same way no entanglement or it can
interact differentially with different
terms in the superposition and that's
when you get entanglement so how do you
actually get it how do you do it well
there's many different ways to do it if
you have two electrons you can zap
lasers at them using entangled photons
and sort of transfer the entanglement to
the electrons let me think of my
favorite example which is the decay of
the Higgs boson I think I didn't talk
about this to you folks I give this
example all the time I give talks on
quantum mechanics so the Higgs boson is
a spin zero particle
so that means that it has no spin at all
it just sits there right it's there it
is not spinning at all we discovered the
Higgs boson in nineteen 2012 I wrote a
book about it I'm not gonna show you the
book but there it is
it's a particle at the end of the
universe one of the things about the
Higgs is it can decay it can decay into
let's say an electron and a positron a
plus and a minus
okay and of course they're gonna go off
in momentum back to back already that's
entangled right this was the original
example we gave of two entangled
particles we had them come in and
scatter so that they were not entangled
when they came in but they scattered
they were instantly entangled because
different ways in which they scatter
matter right if it one scatters along
one direction the other scatters along
the opposite direction boom they're
entangled but this example is a little
bit more clear so the spin of this is
spin zero
there's no spin at all and let's say
these like the Higgs boson is just
sitting there so it decays into electron
and positron they both have spin but
angular momentum is conserved okay so it
must be the case that whatever the spins
are of the electron and the positron
they have to be anti aligned they have
to be going different directions so it
could be and there's a 1 over square
root of 2 out here it could be that the
electron that the positron is spin up
and the electron has spin down or it
could be that the positron is spin down
and the electron has spin up but it is
some entangled superposition of both so
it is trivially easy to make entangled
particles just let a Higgs boson decay
there are easier ways to do it than that
actually pi ons or other particles that
would decay into two spinning particles
also in fact pi ons are probably a very
easy way to do it because a pi on is
easier to make then Higgs boson they're
much lighter easier to produce and they
became two photons moving back to back
and photons are polarized either
spinning clockwise or counterclockwise
along the axis they're going on not
perpendicular to it but the same exact
kind of thing holds the polarizations
the spins of the PI ons have to add to
zero the spins of the photons have to
add to zero since the original PI on
zero spin so it's not at all difficult
to make electron to make entangled
particles finally along this line you
might say what about the double slit
experiment the double slit experiment
remember I'm not gonna do the thick
lines again sorry but you had the source
and then it shot waves of electrons and
they either went through one or the
other then they saw an interference
pattern here like that so there's a it's
very common question why doesn't the
electron going through the slits count
as a measurement all by itself we said
if you added a measurement device to
look to see which slit the electron went
through then you would collapse the
wavefunction you break the interference
pattern but why doesn't the why doesn't
this list themselves detector
why don't they count well the answer is
because the electron does not become
entangled and to be perfectly honest in
the usual way of talking about it that's
just assumed the assumption is the slits
are the barrier whatever is a big heavy
thing and the electron disclaims is off
of it without becoming entangled okay
now you can do better than that
there's this there's a wonderful little
book by yuckier Aronoff is a famous
physicist our own of and oh no I'm gonna
forget the other person's name well he
has a co-author I'm very sorry co-author
roar lick I think it's world like our
own oven or lick a book I think it's
called quantum paradoxes and they ask
all these crazy questions about quantum
mechanics they resolve the paradox is
it's a way to teach you some of the more
advanced features of the foundations of
quantum theory and one thing they do is
say well what if we put our slits on
wheels right like what do we put the
double slit experiment we put it on
wheels so that when the electron goes
through it could actually nudge the
momentum of the slits like the slits are
a quantum mechanical system they have a
wave function they have a center of mass
the momentum the whole bit and then
while you can actually go through the
measurement and you can figure out you
can go through the calculation rather I
think it'd be very hard to do it in a
real experiment but you can go through
the calculation and guess what you know
it depends on how heavy the barrier is
if it's a big heavy thing you
Tron's not going to become dad and
tangled with it it's gonna be exactly
the double slit experiment as we
describe it here if it's a light very
easily disturbed barrier then the
electron will become entangled with it
because the momentum of the electron
going one way will push the barrier in
one direction going the other way will
push in the other one so all this is
just to say there's a little bit of
entanglement that might happen but you
can ignore it if you just do the
experiment correctly and if you don't
want to ignore it you can do the
calculation correctly you can put all
those factors back in get the right
answer you're in good shape ok one tiny
question which I'm not quite sure how to
answer well let me say I'm quite sure
how to answer a question I'm not sure is
decorated to the question that it was
being asked and the question is what
space is the wave function in and what
is meant by this of course I said wave
functions are elements of Hilbert space
this vector space this is set of all
quantum states but if you think about
this experiment we just did one electron
going through the double slits being
detected by the detector
it looks like the wave function sy is
just a function of space and maybe of
time also right so that just looks like
a function of space why is it in it
looks like it the wave function is in
space there it is at every point there's
a value for the wave function why do you
say it's in this big infinite
dimensional vector space so two answers
to that one is of course it depends on
what you need by the word in in is not
necessarily a technical term in physics
or mathematics element of is a technical
term so this idea if you only have one
electron and you ignore its spin so all
it has is a position then indeed the
wave function sy can be thought of as a
map as we talked about before the wave
function at one moment of time is a map
from space r3 to the complex numbers
okay for every location in space there
is a complex number the wave function of
the electron but this does not mean that
size in
trees that in space it means that it's a
function on space that's a different
thing this sigh is an element of hilbert
space which is the space of all possible
wave functions which is infinite
dimensional there's an infinite number
of distinct perpendicular to each other
wave functions that you can imagine
writing down so that's the most trivial
answer to this question is the
difference between being a function on a
space and being an element other space
but there's more sophisticated construal
of what's meant by here when you have
two electrons two particles that's
saying I'll say particles because I
don't want to ignore spins now after
having made a big deal of them and
previously if we have two particles the
wave function as we know is a function
of the positions of both of them okay
that's the origin of the possibility of
entanglement so for that wave function
it's a map from
two copies of space to the complex
numbers right and two copies of space
space is just three dimensional
Euclidean space r3 that's equal to r6
and indeed for n particles SCI works out
to be a map from r3 n to the complex
numbers and this is called configuration
space for n particles
so with his saying is you have some
collection of nparticles you tell me the
set of all possible configurations they
can be in that is the space that a
wavefunction is on that is the space the
wavefunction maps from that space to the
complex numbers and this is why wave
functions are not classical fields
classical fields you know electric field
magnetic field gravitational field all
these fields are independently functions
of space you tell me where you are in
space and I can tell you the
gravitational field magnetic field
electric field etc the wave function is
not once you're beyond one particle you
can't just say Here I am at a point in
space what is the wave function that's
not how it works you have to tell me the
configuration of all the possible
particles and of course as we discussed
sorry trust me as we will discuss very
very soon when you go to field theory it
becomes much more complicated ok then
you have a field all over space and
you're talking about the configuration
space of the field the space of all
possible field configurations is already
a big infinite dimensional space and the
wave function maps that space into the
complex numbers ok so it's a
mathematically a little bit more
abstract nonsensical but it makes
perfect sense you can actually do all
the math in it so even at this level of
saying what what space is the wave
function a function of it's not space ok
it's the configuration space for
whatever thing you're looking at and we
also said by the way that you could
equally well think of the wave function
of a particle as a wave function of
momentum so you can't do both so it's
not a function of position and momentum
its position of position or momentum and
you can do that for n particles also and
the that only makes sense because just
like the set of positions is
three-dimensional the set of momenta
is three-dimensional in fact in any
space of D dimensions if you have a D
dimensional configuration space you're
gonna have a d-dimensional momentum
space also so that's why you can
possibly work out that the wave function
lives equally well in either space ok
people I I do I did want to save this
because people argue a lot about whether
configuration space whether this whole
thing means the configuration space is
real like do we really live in
configuration space this big space if
you have 20 particles this is a 60
dimensional space already and if you
have 10 to the 88th particles you know
you have about 10 to the 88th dimensions
roughly speaking three times in today's
dimensions you really have an infinite
number dimensions once you have a field
and maybe you have less than that with
quantum gravity but anyway I would say
you live in Hilbert space that is what
our universe has a wave function and
that lives in it is an element of
Hilbert space it's a different thing
than being a function Hall in space okay
good good so I think that that's what I
wanted to say about entanglement in the
nature of entanglement and then we can
get into the fun topic of probability in
the many-worlds interpretation again
this is something that I have talked
about before in lectures but we should
mention it here probability not I'm not
going to add the general notion about
the probability with probability in many
worlds many worlds interpretation I said
that interpretation is not the right
word to use for these theories but it's
what people use so there you go this is
the single biggest challenge well this
is one of the two biggest challenges to
many worlds I think one challenge is the
way in which the empirical world around
us which has three dimensional
space-time you know planets and tables
and chairs and people interacting in
almost classical way the emergence of
the classical world or many copies of
the classical world from this big
abstract wavefunction I think that's one
big problem and the other big problem is
the origin of probability I think both
these problems are very solvable that's
why I'm pro many worlds but they're
absolutely out there these are the
respectable problems these are the
issues where if you say I don't believe
in many worlds interpretation because of
this problem
I will go well okay you have a right to
do that okay if you say I don't leaving
the many-worlds interpretation because
it's too many worlds that I'm just gonna
go alright whatever but probability is a
really big problem because in the
textbook formulation
mechanics when you say I have a state of
a qubit that is alpha spin up plus beta
spin down and I say I have a probability
of observing of observing spin up which
is just given by alpha squared and
likewise for beta squared I can't write
and talk at the same time what that
means is something will happen in the
conventional textbook to interpretation
if something will happen I don't know
what will happen
I'll get spin up or spin down but I know
that if I do it over and over again if
I'm a good frequentist about my
probability I can define the probability
of something as what the fraction of
outcomes would be were I to do the
experiment an infinite number of times
okay that's a frequentist notion of
probability that makes perfect sense
with respect to the conventional
Copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics you can imagine measuring a
system in this state over and over over
again every time you measure it the
wavefunction collapses but you can reap
repair it in this state so you can
manipulate your electron with magnetic
fields or lasers or whatever measure it
again do that many many times okay
that's not what happens in many worlds
in many worlds there's no collapse so
what I should do is be very explicit
here in the conventional Copenhagen
interpretation you measure it and then
it becomes this is sy 1 + sy 2 is just
up and that's it with the probability of
alpha squared or it becomes down with
probability down is beta square
so it becomes one or the other whereas
in many worlds so this is textbook in
many worlds sigh one equals alpha and
then you have some apparatus and an
environment can't through the whole
thing right so this is the spin then you
have an apparatus which is in zero state
for the apparatus and zero state for the
environment let me actually move this
out over here you have the spin in a
superposition as before but need to keep
track of everything else there you go
and then time of evolution just time
evolution just means the Schrodinger
equation there's no mystical collapses
or anything like that and you get to
situ we're skipping some steps but it
becomes alpha spin is up apparatus
measured the spin to be up environment
is whatever it was having seen the
apparatus measure it to be spin up plus
beta spin is down apparatus saw it down
environment is whatever the environment
would be in the world where the
apparatus measured the spin to be down
and that's it you're done this is
supposed to be the whole many-worlds
interpretation there's no words in there
about probability of observing anything
but empirically our experimental history
is that when we measure things we get
different probabilities with alpha
squared and beta squared being the
different possibilities we get so here
in this wavefunction both the only thing
to say that has the word probability in
it is with probability one both spin up
and spin down will be observed by
somebody okay will be observed by
somebody on one branch or the other and
so many different attitudes have been
proposed for doing this people have said
well can't you just use as a postulate
that you find yourself in the spin up
branch or the spin down branch with
probability alpha squared or beta
squared that doesn't work there's no
such thing as finding yourself in that
since there is a copy of you that is in
the spin-up branch and there is a copy
of you that is in the spin-down branch
and you know that will be true with
probability 1 ok to the people in these
branches these numbers alpha and beta
they're just going along for the ride
what do they have to do with anything
they didn't touch anything if I live
here if I think that I'm the apparatus
ok so if this is me let me call this the
spin up version to me and this is the
spin down version of me well I don't
know anything about alpha and beta
they're just outside you know
multiplying my world in the wave
function of the universe but who cares
why should I defect my epistemic state
my state about what I know about the
universe ok so the origin of probability
at all in many worlds interpretation is
a common conundrum and what you might
say so one thing is can you say it as a
postulate the answer is no you can't
because these are the postulates are
done the whole idea of many worlds was
there are wave functions there in
Hilbert space they obey the Schrodinger
equation that's it everything else
you're supposed to derive ok no room for
extra postulates the other thing you
could do is maybe each branch has equal
probability right there are two you know
think about if you were if you lived in
a big universe and the universe was so
big much much bigger than the universe
we actually observe outside the universe
was so big that with very high
probability there's an exact copy of you
living somewhere else so it's a very big
universe and someplace bajillions of
light-years away here's you and here's
an exact copy of you or is this one you
and this is the copy which one is you
and which one is the copy they're
identical which one is you well you
don't know maybe you know everything
there is no about the universe but you
don't know which of these two people you
are this is called self locating
uncertainty you know everything there is
to know about the universe except where
you are in it
also sometimes called indexical
uncertainty so one way of dealing with
self locating a certain needs to say
well look these are two copies of me in
the big universe case they're completely
indistinguishable they're identical
locally you know there's not like any
wristband that says I'm the one on the
left okay so I should give fifty-fifty I
should give equal credence as we say the
credence is your degree of personal
belief that you are one or the other
you're completely ignorant there's two
identical situations give them equal
credence therefore equal probability in
a Bayesian way of thinking about
probability as opposed to a frequentist
way a Bayesian thing waiving the
probability says probabilities just
expressions of our ignorance there is
some fact of the matter or there might
be but we don't know okay so when we
talk about the probability that the
Philadelphia 76ers are gonna win the NBA
championship whenever the NBA
championship is next held okay that's
not a frequentist probability they're
not going to have the NBA championship
an infinite number of times at least not
the 2020 NBA championship I'm using this
example intentionally because in my book
something deeply hidden I said we know
that there will be 2020 NBA championship
but we don't know who will win it I did
not anticipate that we don't even know
whether there will be a 2020 NBA
championship this makes me very sad
sorry about that the point is though we
do we use probability talk to discuss
things where we don't know what the
answer is even though there is only one
answer and there's not multiple
different copies there's not multiple
different ways of doing the experiment
over and over again so we talk about
assigning credence 'as in these cases
Bayesian notions of probability are
exactly fitted to that situation where
what probability is is just a measure of
your ignorance and as you gain more
information you can update what your
credence is and then therefore you can
change the cretan PSA's and the
probabilities you assigned to things
okay so this doesn't work this equal
probability this you know let's give
equal credence to all the alternatives
doesn't work in quantum mechanics it
certainly doesn't work in this example I
gave unless alpha and beta or equal to
each other or at least equal to each
other
in magnitude right because that is not
the born rule the born rule says the
probability is alpha squared or beta
squared not 50/50 if alpha was the
square root of 0.99 and beta is the
square root of 0.01 you don't want to
give these equal probabilities also it
shouldn't work right we shouldn't be
surprised that it doesn't work and let
me explain to you why so consider
imagine that you have let's say what's
the right way to do this yeah let's say
that you have two spins okay and they're
both in two spins and they're both once
again I should really plan out these
videos more than I do but they're both
in let's call it spin ah one and spin
too so spin one is an equal
superposition of up and down and so is
spin - and I'll explain why in a second
1 over square root of 2 spin up plus 1
over square 2 spin down I think this is
gonna work I'm gonna have to change the
numbers in a second but okay the point
is you arrange the following situation
you measure the span along the z
direction of spin 1 ok so here you are
with two spins psy 1 psy 2 and then
you're gonna measure a spin 1 and you're
either gonna get spin up or spin down
for a spin 1 okay now there are two
copies of you two branches of the
wavefunction right and you're tempted to
say well I give them equal probability
right that's that maybe you're tempted
to do that let's imagine you're tempted
to do that but then you make an
arrangement with yourself that if you
get spin down you will measure again you
will measure spin too if you don't get
spin down you don't measure spin 2 so
spin 1 is just up here and spin 2 is
just remaining the same but now you
measure spin 2 and you can get spin up
or spin down for spin 2 and now there
are three branches to the wave function
so if you're really consistent here you
want to assign probabilities 1/2 1/2
because there are two branches and you
said I'm gonna assign equal weight to
all the branches but here there are
three branches so you should assign
weight 1/3 1/3 1/3 but what in the world
happened here like if I'm on the spin up
branch and I start by assigning it
probability spin 1/2 and then something
happens on another branch of the wave
function suddenly I should assign a
different probability to my branch that
makes no sense I'm in a different world
my world does not change its probability
just cuz someone else is doing something
in another world ok so this idea that
you weight the branches equally doesn't
work it's just not a starter it's there
is no reason to do it in the first place
and it also doesn't actually pay
okay so let's do a slightly better
example an example that does work so the
thing that you can do that does work is
instead of saying I assign equal
branches to all equal probability to
each branch say to yourself I assign
equal probability to branches that have
the same amplitude okay I assign equal
probability if and only if the wave
function assigns an amplitude to that
branch which is equal to the other
branch okay so now we're seeing that the
amplitudes could matter and that's going
to be important so let me change my
experiment a little bit here no actually
I can keep that I can keep spin to as it
is oops
white good so spin two is still an equal
superposition of spin up and spin down
but imagine that spin one is an unequal
superposition so that I say this is
square root of one third spin up square
root of two thirds spin down let's just
say I'm picking my experiment here okay
and now I start with psy 1 psy two I
measure spin 1 I get either it's up or
it's down I do the same thing if it's up
it's just up if it's down I'm going to
measure spin 2 and I can find that
that's either up or down
and when I'm here either here here
before I've measured spin to the
amplitude here is square root of 1/3 and
the amplitude here is square root of 2/3
so those are not equal and therefore I
say I cannot my rule which says I have
equal probability if I have equal
amplitudes doesn't help me doesn't tell
me what the probability is okay
just doesn't give me any information
also I can't say anything yet but when I
measure spin 2 then this square root of
2/3 gets multiplied by that square root
of 1/2 and now this is 1/3 and this is
1/3 and therefore and this is well it's
the square root of 1/3 the amplitude is
the square root of 1/3 and this is still
the square root of 1/3
and so now these three branches have the
same amplitude square root of 1/3 so now
I can assign them equal probability and
there are three of them and I assign an
equal probability so the equal
probability is 1/3 1/3 1/3 and if I do
that then I know what the probability
was before I measured spin-2 because I
want to make it consistent so if the top
branch has probability 1/3 then it
always did so I put should put a 1/3
here and if the two branches where I
measured spin 2 if they both have
probability 1/3 then the combination of
them better have probability 2/3 right
but you notice that now the
probabilities have assigned are exactly
the amplitude squared that's the born
rule ok
so in many worlds if you make the
argument that branches with equal
amplitudes should be given equal
credence --is that you're on them
you should resolve yourself locating
uncertainty by saying not that I give
every branch equal likelihood but I get
branches equal likelihood when they have
the same wave function when they have
the same amplitude then you derive that
the born rule is the one consistent way
of assigning probabilities in many
worlds now you might argue well even
when the wave function even the
amplitudes are equal why should I get
equal Cretans and that's a longer story
actually that's the whole
part I mean if I had started with saying
that you probably would've said sure
I'll let you do that now you're more a
little skeptical but there are very good
reasons to do that also so this is a
version of an argument that's been given
in different forms by Floyd Tec Zurich
chip cbins my colleague at Caltech and I
wrote a version of this argument that
explicitly uses self locating
uncertainty which Zurich didn't do and
there's another way of proving
many-worlds gets the Warren rule from
decision theory from David Deutsch and
David Wallace so in my mind
we mostly understand there's some fiddly
things here that I think you can still
pick at in terms of the logical
structure of the argument but I'm 98%
happy that the born rule is the right
way to think about probability in many
worlds you can disagree that's okay
there are principled ways of disagreeing
because as I said before you know many
worlds is different the metaphysics of
all these worlds and all these copies of
you is something that we didn't grow up
thinking about okay something that we're
not we haven't developed the mental
technology to really deal with and this
what we're trying to do in experiments
like this in papers like this like Chip
Stevens and I wrote et cetera we're
trying to expand our human logic and way
of thinking to a world where the
wavefunction branches and there many
copies of us we will undoubtedly make
mistakes along the way and maybe it's
all a waste of time because it's not the
right interpretation of quantum
mechanics but it is science we are doing
science we are making progress we can do
better than just say well this makes me
uncomfortable or I don't like it we
actually have to sort of address these
problems head-on and figure them out and
whatever it is as I said in something
deeply hidden many times I am not
invested in many worlds being the
correct interpretation of quantum
mechanics I happen to think it is but if
it turns out to be something else I'm
fine what I'm invested in is people
caring about the many about the correct
interpretation of quantum mechanics
whatever it is we need to figure it out
we there's many reasons we should think
it figured out not only in principle
it's our job to figure things out but
because it will be helpful understanding
physics moving forward there's a lot of
questions in physics
we don't know the answer to
understanding quantum mechanics would
help us quite a bit